watteau soyez les bienvenus voici les
titres de la première phase de ce
journal la sécurité sociale fait de la
pub
en tout cas la caisse maladie dû val de
marne et cela au dos des avis de
remboursement que vous connaissez c'est
une première
jacques chirac a moscou les 14 15 et 16
mai prochain fin donc de l'incertitude
qui avait pesé sur ce voyage le
commentaire de georges bortoli jean paul
ii en allemagne de l'ouest pour cinq
jours avec plusieurs temps forts dont la
béatification de deux victimes du
nazisme football france 2 islande 0 on a
gagné oui mais il n'y a pas de quoi le
crier sur toutes les pelouses car selon
les spécialistes il n'y avait pas la
manière l'occasion pour nous de revenir
sur la révélation de ce match
le jeune niche et puis nous recevrons
monsieur bachelot député du front
national un parti dont les propositions
pour l'emploi ont été mises en cause
hier à l'assemblée par philippe seguin
et tout à l'heure en fin de journal
charlotte rampling seul et unique et
ruines d'un livre il s'agit d'un album
de photos qui lui est consacré et qui
retrace quelques étapes de sa carrière
la météo maintenant fin provisoire jeudi
bien provisoire du printemps les
prévisions dans un instant avec alain
chaufour voilà pour le sommaire de cette
édition
aujourd'hui jeudi 30 avril 1987 un jour
de détention supplémentaires pour les
diplomates français marcel fontaine et
marcel carton pour notre confrère jean
paul kauffmann et pour notre ami
l'antenne de jean louis normandin les
otages détenus au liban ne sont toujours
pas libérés
la sécurité sociale fait de la pub si
vous permettez ce raccourci pour
l'instant c'est une expérience tentée
par la caisse d'assurance maladie dû val
de marne et qui est limité à ce
département c'est simple au verso des
avis de remboursement que vous
connaissez comme celui-ci et bien figure
une publicité là c'est pour une
publication littéraire c'est pour une
collection mais ça peut être aussi pour
des assurances etc
oui mais me direz-vous une caisse
d'assurance n'a pas le droit de se faire
payer un tel service est vrai alors
c'est instaurer un système des changes
que va vous expliquer et remettez qui
vous révèle cette affaire et qui permet
à la caisse d'assurance en question
d'économiser 1 millions de francs par an
m m'étais promis
les rois maudits dans une édition livre
cadeau un contrat d'assurance vie
un système d'alarmé une encyclopédie
médicale ou même une méthode pour
maigrir
autant de sujets d'étonnement pour les
assurés sociaux du val de marne
quand ils ont découvert ces publicités
au dos des avis de remboursement que le
renvoi la sécurité sociale l'idée est
simple le verso des avis de
remboursement est en vierge
le directeur de la caisse de créteil a
pensé en confier les usages à un
publicitaire celui ci a sauté sur
l'occasion
l'intérêt pour un annonceur de ce
nouveau support c'est sa fiabilité
fiabilité parce que 96% des français
sont assurés sociaux parce que ce
message est un message positif qui
ramène tout de même un remboursement à
des dépenses qui ont été faites et que
nous savons que ce message est ouvert il
n'est pas jeté comme bien des mailings
qui sont déposées dans les boîtes aux
lettres
cela est ouvert et ont observé une
caisse d'assurance maladie il n'a pas le
droit de recevoir d'argent alors
pourquoi de la pub allez vous dire en
échange de la vente dépasse le
publicitaire assure l'impression
gratuite des 30000 à vis de
remboursement que la caisse en voit
chaque jour
l'économie se monte à 1 million de
francs pour l'année
j'exerce une censure constante sur les
sujets de publicité qui nous sont
proposés bien entendu nous excluons tout
ce qui n'est pas dans le droit fil de la
mission de l'institution nous excluant
l'alcool même la bière
nous excluons le tabac nous excluons les
corps crâne c'est que souvent les
régimes d'assurances complémentaires
nous excluons tous ceux qui encore une
fois peut paraître contradictoire avec
la finalité de sécurité sociale outre le
contrôle sur le contenu des pubs la
caisse a tenu à moraliser l'opération le
tiers de l'espace vendus dans l'année
servira à des campagnes de santé
publique contre la carie dentaire la
drogue ou le sida la pub
une bonne façon de faire des économies
les avis des assurés sociaux font mitigé
effectivement j'ai reçu - déjà des
décomptes
de la publicité au dos je suis pas
montre du tour fbi stands on voit
partout on en voit à la télé dans les
journaux
pourquoi pas autour des décomptes
sécurité sociale pour moi je trouve ça
tout à fait scandaleux qu'on que dans le
même temps on réduise les remboursements
aux assurés
conte
qui se voyait refuser un certain nombre
de remboursements et que on leur dise
placé bien votre argent avec la gmf
nosta je trouve ça tout à fait
scandaleux si ça peut apporter quelque
chose à la sécurité sociale ça peut être
positif
il faut voir le résultat la caisse
nationale d'assurance maladie a fait
connaître ses réserves devant
l'initiative de créteil mais déjà la
caisse d'allocations familiales de
bordeaux annonce si elle mettra de la
pub au dos de ces enveloppes la sécu du
val de marne fait des émules
voilà vous avez bien compris il s'agit
pour l'instant du val de marne
la météo maintenant puisque certains
d'entre vous en la chance de pouvoir
lever le pied et dès cet après midi nous
disions dans les titres de cette édition
au revoir le printemps mais j'espère
alain chaufour qu'il ne s'agit qu'un au
revoir que dans leur foi on l'espère
nous aussi william en tout cas la
météorologie nationale n'est pas très
optimiste pour ce premier week-end de
mai et avant l'apothéose de dimanche et
du début de semaine où l'on verra à
l'attorney température baisser de
quelques 10 à 12 degrés sur pratiquement
l'ensemble du pays est bien dès
aujourd'hui la partie nord du pays et
sous les nuages et sous les averses et
la partie sud bénéficie d'un petit répit
regardons d'abord la carte du temps
prévu pour l'après midi c'est ce sont
les perturbations qui ont traversé toute
la france en diagonale
au cours de la nuit au cours de la
matinée qui vont se localiser dans
l'après midi plutôt sur une partie nord
dit long sur les régions nord ile de
france centre du pays même jusqu'à
l'auvergne et peut-être jusqu'à la
région lyonnaise et surtout donc sur la
franche comté le jura l'alsace lorraine
à l'arrière de cette zone
des éclaircies mais quand même avec
quelques passages nuageux et puis je
vous le disais au sud un temps beaucoup
plus claire et beaucoup plus ensoleillé
à noter quand même quelques passages
nuageux assez importants sur le bassin
méditerranéen et quelques nuages avec
des transports à jose sur les alpes
alors comment tout cela va-t-il évoluer
pour deux mais bien un petit répit
demain puisque une nouvelle perturbation
arrive mais elle n'a quittera cette fois
ci que la partie nord-ouest du pays avec
passages nuageux et quelques pluies plus
ou moins importantes sur les côtes de la
manche et je vous le disais sur les
régions nord picardie également ile de
france et normandie ailleurs attend
beaucoup plus beaux quelques brouillards
matinaux dans le centre de la france et
puis ces nuages et ses pluies qui était
donc aujourd'hui sur l'est du pays et
sur le centre vont se décaler et
quelques résidus nuit
je viendrai inquiétait demain la région
des alpes est un petit peu le nord de la
provence côte d'azur partout ailleurs
vous le voyez c'est du très beau temps
je vous le disais samedi et dimanche les
températures vont baisser énormément dès
aujourd'hui elle commence par perdre
quelques petits degrés regardons les sur
la carte des températures pour l'après
midi de 16 degrés à brest et à cherbourg
nous irons jusqu'à 23 degrés à
strasbourg oublier les beaux 26 et 27 de
ces jours derniers 20 à paris et pour la
partie sud est bien de 18° à nantes
nous irons jusqu'à 23 degrés aussi bien
à biarritz car grenoble
et puis ce premier week-end de mai
valait bien sûr l'occasion de nombreux
départs alors regardez les conseils de
bison futé qui vous demandent d'éviter
de partir aujourd'hui des grandes
métropoles enfin des grandes villes
françaises entre 15 et 21h en tout cas
même si le ciel est un petit peu voilé
un petit peu plus vieux bon week end
merci à propos du pont du 1er mai
peut-être faudrait-il par les deux
viaducs
car dès cet après midi et jusqu'à lundi
matin certain nombre de bureaux et de
commerces fermeront pour cause de 1er
mai voici le détail
si vous devez prendre le train le bus ou
le métro prenez vos précautions demain
le trafic sera réduit comme les
dimanches et les jours fériés
en revanche ne vous attendez pas
recevoir de courrier il n'ya pouvoir
entrer dans un bureau de poste ou dans
une banque
ces guichets seront fermés demain toute
la journée et même pendant trois jours
dans le cas de certaines banques celles
qui ne sont pas ouvertes le samedi comme
à paris porte close également à l'entrée
des pharmacies des caisses de sécurité
sociale et des mairies avec une nuance
pour les pharmacies le service de garde
les dimanches et les jours fériés
étaient prévues la plupart des monuments
des musées nationaux comme le centre
georges pompidou seront deux aussi fermé
pas question non plus demain matin
d'acheter votre quotidien habituel dans
les kiosques mais vous pourrez écouter
la radio ou regarder la télévision
et pourquoi pas choisir antenne 2 et
j'ajoute ceci qui est très important
pour une grande partie d'entre vous
la confédération des hôteliers
restaurateurs cafetiers et discothèques
a déposé un préavis de grève pour les
enjeux du pmu le 1er mai donc attention
pour vos paris demain la confédération
réclame une hausse de la commission que
perçoivent les établissements il faut
savoir que la commission n'a pas varié
depuis 50 ans feu vert pour jacques
chirac à moscou dans une quinzaine de
jours vous souvenez que le doute avait
plané sur cette visite du premier
ministre en union soviétique certes
jacques chirac avait été invité mais
pour diverses raisons aucune date
n'avait été
et précisé à l'époque c'était au début
avril on avait pensé que le
chassé-croisé d'expulsion de diplomates
soviétiques et français n'avait pas
arranger le climat
l'annnonce de ce voyage a été faite
officiellement par le porte-parole du
premier ministre monsieur beaudoin ce
matin le premier ministre de la
république française se rendra en visite
officielle en union soviétique
au milieu du mois de mai prochain à
l'invitation du gouvernement soviétique
j'ajoute que ce voyage aura lieu du 14
au 17 mai prochain inutile de vous
souligner dans le moment nous nous
trouvons avec toutes les propositions de
désarmement qui ont été faites par le
gouvernement soviétique et qui sont
actuellement en discussion en
particulier avec le gouvernement
américain
l'importance que peut avoir cette
rencontre du premier ministre français
chef du gouvernement avec monsieur
gorbatchev afin de l'avoir toute une
série d'informations et de faire
connaître aussi aux soviétiques
la position française l'invitation des
soviétiques à monsieur chirac date de
longtemps déjà mais la date officielle
du voyage n'a été précisé qu'aujourd'hui
c'est à dire très tard et cela parce que
l'on a attendu d'avoir du coût des
français les satisfactions qu'on jugeait
nécessaires et si l'on est satisfait à
l'hôtel matignon
c'est parce que ce voyage sera d'une
part assez long et d'autres pas assez
rempli d'entretiens avec monsieur
gorbatchev pour que les sujets traités
soient traitées vraiment en profondeur
alors certes avant-hier encore l'agent
soviétique tas se critiquer le bruit
istres français parce qu'elle jugeait
qu'il n'était pas assez favorable aux
propositions de désarmement de monsieur
gorbatchev
il fait le temple est normal que les
expulsions de diplomates soviétiques ne
sont pas tout à fait oublié elle non
plus mais on rappelle côté français que
madame cette chère elle aussi était
critiquée lorsqu'elle est arrivée à
moscou pour les médias soviétique ce qui
n'a pas empêché ces entretiens d'être
tout à fait fructueux
il va bien falloir détruire l'ambassade
américaine à moscou elle est à peine
construite et encore inoccupés motive
vous le connaissez les autorités
américaines accusent des soviétiques
d'avoir truffé les bâtiments que voici
truffé de micros alors ça va coûter très
cher aux contribuables américains mais
paraît-il le secret est à ce prix nous
vous parlions hier du sondage bv à
paris-match qui faisait apparaître entre
autres choses une forte cote de
popularité pour le président de la
république monsieur mitterrand sur ce
sujet voici le commentaire de pierre
messmer président du groupe rpr à
l'assemblée dans télématin en réponse
aux questions de pôle nord le président
de république n'est plus depuis un an
responsable de la politique que
française jean pas tuer tout ce qui
touche à la politique intérieure
par conséquent il n'a pas la
responsabilité qu'il avait autrefois les
mesures qui sont considérés comme
impopulaire et comme c'est un homme
habile et qu'il distribue des bons
points des mauvais points de temps en
temps qui se fait voir à droite et à
gauche en province et à paris il a pris
la popularité que les présidents de la
république de la troisième avait parce
que inaugurer les chrysanthèmes et à
propos d'une ou de plusieurs
candidatures de la majorité à l'élection
présidentielle monsieur messmer s'est
déclaré favorable à une double
candidature au premier tour
quant aux dissensions qu'on a pu
observer ces derniers temps dans la
majorité c'est toujours mauvais dit
monsieur messmer quelle que soit la
majorité parce que ça en diminue
l'autorité le front national au centre
d'une double polémique qui a après midi
à l'assemblée nationale monsieur jacques
chirac à qui on demandait de se situer
par rapport à cette formation expliqué
que le front national était dans
l'opposition
au même titre que les socialistes et les
communistes d'autre part monsieur séguin
a répondu aux propositions de jean marie
le pen disant a accordé une priorité aux
français en matière d'emploi je le cite
il s'agirait alors de mesures
discriminatoires et que les difficultés
actuelles ne seraient conduire à des
politiques simpliste et démagogique et
puis le ministre des affaires sociales
grand amateur de football a pris un
exemple à propos de l'idée priorité aux
français écouter
la france n'avait pas été fidèle aux
traditions sont les siennes si la france
avait souscrit aux principes auxquels
vous vous référez ce soir
la france joue récent numéro 200 numéros
400 numéro 6 jean numéro 7 dans numéro
bien sûr sans numéro 10 est un coup
voyez que je n'ai pu faire la différence
entre vous et nous c'est que nous
voulons donner toutes ses chances à la
france
nous recevons monsieur bachelot françois
bachelot qui est député de la
seine-saint-denis du front national vous
ai été l'air hier à l'assemblée quand
vous avez entendu monsieur séguin alors
on va reparler de votre situation dans
l'opposition mais tout de suite
revenons-en à ce que disait le ministre
le numéro 7 s'est mis chier je crois il
a marqué d'ailleurs un bus vers soir
vous pourrez prendre sur le ton de la
boutade je dirais qu'à la vitesse
monsieur seguin créer des chômeurs d'ici
quelques mois il y aura plus de français
pour acheter les billets pour aller voir
les matchs de foot
mais sur le fond et le sujet justement
julliard le sujet est beaucoup plus
sérieux alors qu'est ce que nous disons
nous disant nous voulons donner un
emploi à chaque français et à chaque
ressortissant de la communauté
européenne
donc nos amis italiens espagnols
portugais et aucun problème parce que
c'est la normale non c'est la solidarité
nationale
est-ce que c'est illégal non l'allemagne
depuis 73 le fait est ce que c'est
urgent oui il ya trois millions deux
cent mille chômeurs plus de 150000
depuis que monsieur seguin savez ce que
c'est efficace
oui l'allemagne crée des emplois et on
sait qu'à peu près un emploi sur deux
qui seraient libérés
ce recul conséquent la question qu'il
faut poser pourquoi systématique le rpr
et l'udf à ceux ci leur voix aux
socialistes et communistes pour voté
contre une proposition de donner un
emploi chaque nom ses réponses et les
seins c'est qu'ils en ont fait une
fatalité bien nous nous disons non c'est
pas une vérité n'abandonnons pas les
c'est lui que vous parliez du rpr qui
associe ses voix au parti socialiste le
parti communiste parce que le premier
ministre vous disais hier que la plupart
du temps vous votiez avec les
socialistes et les communistes comme si
vous vouliez si vous voulez les
remercier de vous avoir fait rentrer en
force à l'assemblée avec la
proportionnelle ce n'est pas le cas pour
nous les chiffes cherche l'amour
téléspectateurs le père père et lui
d'air à voter soit 106 x avec le parti
socialiste et le parti communiste le
mois les deux camps la fois depuis le
début de l'année je suis député voilà la
leçon jalonnent lequel la première leçon
de jeunes députés ses clients un
décalage permanent mais la ville les
statures
salut j'ai l'arrivée je suis arrivé en
mars quatre moines et bien depuis que
mars 86
ils ont voté 66 fois ensemble et c'est
nous qu'on d'herning du doigt alors ils
vous répondront à cela comme on a déjà
pu suggérer sûr ici at-elle expliqué
alors on dit on dise à un ministre de la
majorité il vous dira c'est que notre
proposition était bonne et les
socialistes et les communistes ils sont
associés place d'une web montrent acte
quand les projets du gouvernement était
satisfaisant ou aller dans le bon sens
nous les avons voté 400 fut longtemps et
qu il 400 fois avec leur père et lui
l'aise quand c'était mauvais pour les
français eh bien nous avons dit nous et
c'est et notre propos cohérent homogène
combien de fois vous avez voté avec
alors est ce qu'on a le renvoi pour les
votes de confiance et à chaque fois
qu'on a remis en cause mais c'est les
votes et puis c'est important un vote de
confiance et vous donner un ticket pour
que le gouvernement continue tout à fait
c'est un vote de netteté nous avons dit
ce qu'il propose va échouer
non nous avons fait une confiance de une
motion de défiance n'est pas ayant
échoué au bout d'un an nous avons été
courir car ces mauvais ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui pour le feu mais quand vous
tirez les choux mais encore vous ne
voulez pas la conséquence est pas la
conscience vous ne votez pas pour ce
gouvernement vous votez donc avec
l'opposition c'est ce que disait hier le
premier ministre vous voulez chasser ce
gouvernement là vous êtes méridienne
allô police ont refusé le droit à la
différence et ce sur une forme
d'intolérance quelques regrets est ce
qu'on doit pas voir deux oppositions
vous savez très bien qu'on a rien après
tout communiste que nous combattons
depuis très longtemps
alors de grâce arrêtons ce faux procès
événement au fond déchu alors est-ce
qu'il faut créer des emplois et comment
alors nous on a proposé
on a diffusé un papier en dix points et
on a fait des choses pas si c'est ce qui
gêne dérange
nous dérangeons parce que nous
l'abordons les problèmes au fond avec
des solutions non l oeuvre vos
propositions et d'après ce que disait
monsieur ce gars sont plus entachée de
moralité c'est bien ça qui les hacker
les a gênés en disant si vous rend
supprimé il a pris l'exemple du football
si vous supprimiez d'arrivée de ces
étrangers qu'on a naturalisé si cette
mesure a été prise avant regarder il
nous manquerait beaucoup de français
utilisent je dirais des français qui ont
fait parler d'eux et et bien c'est pour
ça qu'il a parlé de niche et d'acteurs
et de d'artistes et de d'écrivain
homme politique monsieur stasi le
syndicalisme c'est krasucki je peux
continuer un manque de prudence
c'est essentiel cette deuxième aspect de
la chose c'est l'aspect politique qu'est
ce que j'observe
j'observe premièrement que le front
national est au centre de la vie
politique française
pourquoi parce que le front national est
devenu le parti d'intérêt c'est un
nouveau parti c'est un parti de vérité
alors tout le monde s'occupe d'eux c'est
ma première remarque d'un côté comme de
l'autre on dit qu est-ce qui va voir le
front national sera au tour de rôle
oui enfin c'est intéressant c'est vrai
vous êtes et qui dernier n'est pas l'été
dernier car si on était petits derrières
jeudi dernier en est où je veux dire en
aient une partie à part entière de la
vie politique aux spectateurs environ
deuxième remarque c'est que je constate
une perte de sens de tous les ministres
qui ont échoué que ce soit monsieur
malgré avec la mort de cette étude que
ce soit monsieur rossinot qui crée une
discorde dans le parlement
madame barsacq qui a fait perdre un nom
d' entre la course de vitesse contre le
sida
monsieur séguin qui serait chômeurs
alors monsieur bachand bien je vais vous
exprimer à l'assemblée y en a eu à
nantes n'ayant pas à l'assemblée il
n'ayant pas l'occasion si vous voulez de
proposer ils ont pris la voie de neige
et c'est ce que nous refusons c'est
parce que c'est pas normal que tous ces
sujets là par exemple on nous a même
toujours à auch 8 jeudi c'est une injure
c'est une injure pour toutes ces
victimes de l'holocauste
et je le dis très clairement c'est une
injure pour le peuple français que de
mépriser le débat d'idées alors j'ai
appel à beaucoup de calme et de sérénité
car on a une certaine angoisse de voir
que des ministres qui ont des
responsabilités essentielles se laisse
aller à la déprime et à l'injure je dis
quoi s'agit-il
les gens conclut nous n'avons aucune
haine nous avons simplement une
préoccupation de vigilance une
préoccupation de responsabilité je
demanderai dans l'intérêt des français
de tout le monde qu'on en vienne très
chaud le débat de fond en forme mais sur
le fond est ce qu a dit monsieur seguin
hier vous n'êtes pas content non j'ai
pas contre tous les trains les arts la
musique la culture
six ans merci monsieur basto parlons du
football précisément puisque nous étions
il ya un instant alors on a gagné vous
le savez mais aujourd'hui les
spécialistes ne le murmure plus tôt
qu'il ne le crient 2 à 0 contre
l'islande hier soir au parc des princes
grâce à miss chic dont nous voulons
parler et à stopyra et l'équipe
nationale garde un petit espoir de se
qualifier pour la phase finale du
championnat d'europe mais ils ne font
plus rien perdre ça c'est l'enjeu voyons
de plus près maintenant la révélation de
ce match carmelo miche dominique le mot
la première marseillaise de carmelo mais
dans sa tête comme dans celle de platini
un autre hymne et oui on est attaché à
sa terre d'accueil
la lorraine quand on est italien
d'origine catholique et respectueux des
valeurs platini en est une ce ballon
lobé en est la plus parfaite
illustration
carmelo lui a tout à prouver à 24 ans
c'est sa première sélection
et même si avec mais si la midouze but
le grand public le découvre seulement
alors ses premières minutes sont
difficiles il a besoin de se libérer
la clé c'est platini qui va lui donner
un platini contrer côté pile un platini
éclairé côté face et voilà bull blog
premier de carmelo 1600 l'équipe de
france mais ça s'était préparé à
l'entraînement michel lui avait tout
expliqué à carmelo solidarité italienne
solidarité lorraine et il a compris
carmelo il a piqué à gauche
rod restait du droit c'est du beau
travail construisit un série talent
libéré il donne alors le tournis à son
vis-à-vis mais hélas l'équipe de france
n'était pas dans un bon jour
alors il permet change d'aile accélère
bouge sans cesse
se retrouve de l'autre côté bree bhl
déborde centre en retrait est hélas il
n'y a personne mais la france elle vient
de trouver un ailier un vrai numéro 7
elle en avait bien besoin
depuis le temps qu'on cherchait
désespérément cette démarche à la
garrincha regardez le résultat la
défense islandaise est déséquilibré
carmelo lui et triomphants car son
centre amène le deuxième but français
car yannick stopyra a suivi jaillit
rouler bouler et marqué avec chance mais
il a marqué
merci mi6 un bonheur partagé par un
homme qui croit et qui croient
superstitieux je croyais en biais de
médias etc
j'ai par tout temps avoir d'éléments non
récurrents ça me fait ça me motive ça me
protège a plu
voilà et quand ils rentrent sur le
terrain il embrasse s'accroît comme
beaucoup de sud américains comme le
faisait remarquer dominique le goût
alors ceci aussi le président de la
république et le premier ministre sont
d'accord pour nous aider et
reconnaissent l'importance de notre
action contre la toxicomanie c'est ce
qu'a déclaré ce matin michel platini ali
matters de la fondation aide aux jeunes
drogués vous le voyez là le footballeur
a été reçue pendant près d'une heure à
l'elysée en compagnie et sur votre image
c'est le troisième en partant de la
gauche en compagnie du docteur claude
olievenstein les policiers et miliciens
suspendu robert pandraud le ministre
chargé de la sécurité a décidé de
suspendre en attendant les conclusions
de l'enquêté le commandant du corps
urbain de la courneuve et trois autres
policiers qui travaillaient au noir dans
une milice patronale
pascal stelletta roger motte
ces deux hommes masqués de foulards
évacués par des crs d'une usine de la
banlieue parisienne sont eux mêmes des
policiers après leurs heures de service
ils louaient leurs talents à des milices
patronales spécialisée dans les
opérations musclées
lusine slower de dammarie près de melun
n'est pas rentable
ainsi on a décidé son propriétaire le
docteur klaus voormann le patron des
patrons allemands sur le site
on prévoit la création d'un port de
plaisance et des appartements de grand
standing
la liquidation doit être terminé avant
le 16 avril
le directeur français de lusine claude
collard n'a pas de temps à perdre en
négociation les ouvriers occupent les
usines cette situation bloquée le
directeur va chercher à la règle et à sa
façon à la tête d'une milice recruté
pour l'occasion il investit lusine dans
la nuit du 12 au 13 avril
et puis vers 4h 12 84% chez nous en dise
quelques autres qui reprend les jeunes
en accords
gentiment oui gentiment ils sont arrivés
dans des robes a pas de violence envers
grande usine si gentil je vote pas de
l'avoir gardé
donc j'ai remis mes deux collègues et
pour nous parti quoi ils étaient les
mains dans les poches
non non il avait été acquis ou équiper
tous puis avec les asiatiques avaient
des battes de baseball et puis des
grilles de fer les 25 gros bras vont
pouvoir travailler toute la nuit sans
être dérangé tout le matériel a été
préparé à à quitter l'entreprise et s'il
n'ya pas y aurait pas eu d'intervention
de la population d'amérique est venu à
notre soutien pour faire sortir ses
commandos là il y avait deux camions de
38 tonnes qui étaient prêts à sortir
tout ce matériel tout ce matériel à quai
sur palette vous côté de la direction
toujours la même réponse
au petit matin les ouvriers la
population se mobilise la police de
melun intervient lusine est encerclée
par les forces de l'ordre
parmi les hommes du commando interpellé
quatre policiers en civil l'un d'eux
henry léman et commandant d'un corps
urbain de la courneuve
bon je crois que c'est tout à fait le
genre d'affaires regrettable et je peux
pas dire que la phase grand bien à la
police nationale je ne sois pas c'est
pas les gens d'affaires qui peut
rehausser le prestige
d'après leurs enchaînements du jeu il
semblerait que ce soit de l'excellent
fonctionnaires de police
ce qui est peut-être malheureux d'un
songe à la verse et que chez
fonctionnaires ont participé à cette
opération peut-être je crois qu'il faut
pas il faut le reconnaître tout
simplement pour se faire un peu d'argent
je crois que c'est ce qu'ils étaient
venus l'écouter on peut pas on peut pas
on ne peut pas l'accepter
en attendant les résultats de l'enquêté
de l'inspection générale de la police
le ministre délégué à la sécurité robert
pandraud a suspendu les quatre policiers
de leurs fonctions de leur côté les
ouvriers de l'usiné en porter plainte
du nouveau pour la carte scolaire les
parents vont désormais avoir plus de
choix pour inscrire leur enfant en
sixième ce que ce que prévoient une
circulaire publiée aujourd'hui par le
ministère de l'éducation
nous allons avoir le détail avec lauren
cuisine dans un instant je vous rappelle
que jusqu'à présent les enfants sont
automatiquement affectés dans un
établissement qui dépend de leur lieu
d'habitation
l'expérience conduite ces dernières
années qui conclurent d'ailleurs dans 11
départements va pouvoir s'étendre
maintenant à 74 départements
ça concerne 520 un collège et par ici
mais également lorraine fusain
hervé en osant entre en sixième en
septembre élèves d'une école primaire du
20e a paris il pourra aller dans trois
collèges du quartier celui du secteur de
son domicile ou deux autres très voisins
mais auquel il n'aurait pu accéder
librement jusqu alors ses parents
entendent bien profiter de cette
possibilité de choix si je regarde les
trois établissements qui me sont
proposées il y en a un qui est quand
même plus proche du domicile ce qui
permettra quand même d'être plus
rapidement à l'école d'être plus tôt à
la maison à la sortie et la deuxième ma
deuxième préoccupation c'est de lui
avoir cassé ses habitudes depuis la
maternelle il a pratiquement les mêmes
camarades et il a plutôt tendance à se
laisser entraîner
bon ça nous arrive d'avoir le soir des
petits mots sur les carnets de
correspondance à ce sujet là dans ce
quartier comme pour la plupart des
expériences les parents pour opter entre
2 à 5 établissements
un choix encore limitée quatre
arrondissements concernés à paris et sur
toute la france à peine 10% des collèges
et bien souvent les établissements les
plus réputés sont exclus des secteurs de
libre choix
bref une opération prudente des marrons
certains certains départements ont
conduit des expériences les années
précédentes
c'est la première fois que nous
commençons à paris notre but est bien de
dire la vérité et n'est pas de laisser
laisser croire que le
le choix un choix absolu va être
possible nous serons obligés de tenir
compte des capacités d'accueil des
structures des établissements et des
contraintes qui existe à question donc
de voir certains collèges se vidèrent au
profit d'autres si un établissement est
trop demander une commission locale
composée de l'inspecteur de parents des
chefs d'établissement et d'élus définira
les critères d'affectation jamais les
notes de l'enfant ne devront être un
critère reste un problème comment les
familles vont-elles s'informer
objectivement le bouche à oreille est
pour beaucoup dans le choix des
établissements les parents discutent
entre eux et bien il ya des rumeurs qui
existent réputation réputation et ça
c'est quand même regrettable
les parents désirent une information
plus transparente
certains souhaiteraient même qu'on
procède à une évaluation des collèges
de son côté le ministère pour l'instant
ainsi que les établissements à mieux se
faire connaître
la hausse des dépenses médicales a
nettement ralenti depuis le 1er janvier
alors que c'est l inverse depuis deux
ans et puis également ceux ci le
ministère des transports annonce la
levée des préavis de grève des
aiguilleurs du ciel
seule est maintenue sur le préavis de la
cgt pour les 4 et 7 mai prochains de
6h30 à 9h alcoolo bobos nous avons
souvent parlé ici même des dangers de
l'alcool au volant et parallèlement aux
décisions prises par le garde des sceaux
en faveur d'une aggravation des peines
pour les chauffards ivres et bien un
restaurateur près de rennes a une idée
d'abord ça va faire parler de lui ça
n'empêche pas la vente d'alcool dans son
établissement
et en plus ça peut contribuer à sauver
des vies humaines
ça fait trois bonnes raisons patrice
voler une idée unique en france faire
jouer les clients des restaurants ou
plutôt les faire parier parier que le
chauffeur de la voiture pour une soirée
ne boira pas d'alcool au cours ne sont
pas
pas trop boire vous aurez demi et avec
lui le repas des noirs pour des riffs et
ça tout à l'heure mais souffler dans le
ballon
bonjour d'accord paris informé si vous
perdez vous payer plein tarif était mal
coté à paris ouais on y va parce que ça
vous coûte cher cette expérience à prime
abord ça ça peut sembler coûter cher
néanmoins il faut bien penser que les
gens qui nous disaient qu'ils ont décidé
de reconduire vont consommer plus donc
ce qui veut dire que je pense que les
équilibres financiers on va le retrouver
d'une façon ou d'une autre
d'autre part ce qui me coûte cher
franchement c'est les alcootests parce
que autant d'aspects d'expérience et les
préventif autant de prix due date me
tester disposif prix unitaire de
l'alcootest 22 francs 50 et selon le
restaurateur des ballons difficiles à
acheter en grande quantité après le
dessert vérification des promesses
faites à l'heure de l'apéro games et
gagner
j'ai roulé moins pour compenser le
restaurateur offre des jus de fruits au
prix coûtant publicité bien sûr mais
aussi vrai souci de lutter contre
l'alcoolisme
avec le soutien des gendarmes d'ille et
vilaine
parce que ça donne
même pas une perversion rien du tout
c'est vrai dans leur majorité les
clients jouent le jeu
un retour sans problème vaut bien un
repas sans alcool jean paul 2 5 jours en
allemagne de l'ouest c'est un voyage
tour de force comme c'est souvent le cas
pour le saint père puisqu'il doit
visiter 11 villes du nord-ouest au
sud-est de ce pays l'occasion pour nous
de mieux faire connaissance avec
l'église catholique d'allemagne de
l'ouest que l'on connaît mal et d'abord
ceux ci c'est la première église dans
son pays juste devant juste devant les
protestants ce qui n'empêche pas d'être
en crise jean-claude d'allégories
pourquoi il ya une crise parce qu'on
peut dire que depuis un certain nombre
d'années les fidèles ont une certaine
désaffection pour une église qui leur
paraît une église lourdes liées au monde
de l'argent alors je crois qu'il ya des
chiffres quand même a donné qu'ils sont
importants
le diocèse de cologne à les revenus qui
sont supérieurs à ceux du vatican pour
une année alors ça vient d'où ma vie
très sagement les extrêmement riche ça
vient d'une chose très très précis c'est
que les ministres du culte aussi bien
d'ailleurs catholiques protestants que
juifs sont rétribués par l'état alors
qu'elle ça veut dire d'une manière très
concrète sur votre fiche d'impôts
williams si vous étiez en république
fédérale allemande sûrs et marqué votre
religion
tant que vous ne récuse et pas votre
religion une ponction est fait sur vos
impôts et ses impôts sont reversés aux
églises donc les existants des
disponibilités considérables qu'elles
utilisent il faut le dire pour être
juste a pas mal de choses
bien sûr à faire vivre une église qui a
pas mal d'institutions mais aussi
qu'elle énormément le terrain alors au
sens propre du terme je dire on a
intérêt à récuser sa religion
sur le plan financier on a été bons on
peut aller les viser dimanche mais sur
la feuille d'impôts du bas que je ne
suis pas alors je crois que peut-être
que les allemands sont peu savent aussi
fainéant que nous le sommes je crois que
très souvent cei pour refaire une
feuille d'impôts c'est très difficile à
l'orias il ya beaucoup de gens qui
préfèrent laisser cela et ils sont
ponctionnés habituellement ça fait
partie de leurs habitudes
le sait le régime concordataire l'état a
signé avec l'église un concordat en
allemand au fener je suis pas sûr que ce
soit le
il convient alors le pape va procéder ça
c'est très important à 2 béatification
ce qui va involontairement je dis bien
involontairement relancer une polémique
là bas sur le passé des allemands entre
les partisans de l'oubli définitif et
puis les autres qui souhaitent que l'on
témoigne toujours oui d'autant plus que
parmi ces deux allemands qui vont être
canonisé il y en a il ya une allemande
qui est un peu particulière puisqu'elle
est d'origine juive
edith stein va être béatifié c'est une
jeune femme qui était donc d'origine
juive libérale à face et parents étaient
à tf1 n'avait pas de pratique religieuse
particulière
après une évolution spirituelle elle
même s'est converti au catholicisme
elle a été exclu de l'université car
était professeur de philosophie pour
parce qu'elle était juive elle est
rentrée au carmel et c'est à l'occasion
d'une visite forcée du carmel où elle se
trouvait que les ss son entrée elle
s'est déclarée juive elle a voulu jouer
la carte de la solidarité avec le
judaïsme
elle était amenée à auschwitz et elle a
disparu tout la polémique des
communautés juives qui disent voilà les
catholiques récupère encore une des
victimes du show merci jean claude de
toute façon nous parlerons une ronde
rencontre de ce voyage dès dès ce soir
dans notre journal de 20 heures puisque
sa sainteté arrivèrent 17 en france
merci la bourse maintenant avec jean le
bot pour savoir si la séance a été aussi
irrégulière qui hier aujourd'hui jean un
long week end williams tout en gardant
un oeil sur la rencontre américano
japonaise
elle ne sait pas sur quel pied danser
légèrement positive ce matin puis
négative puis à nouveau légèrement
positif on peut dire que l'indicateur de
tendance évolue en dents de scie en
clair on expédie les affaires courantes
sur notre table ont quelques plus fortes
hausses que l'on doit à la publication
de bons résultats comme pour la
lyonnaise des eaux qui gagne 2 et demi
pour cent ou sommer allibert au plus
haut de l'année qui double ses bénéfices
ou encore total à 60 francs qui gagne
1,1 pour cent la valeur du jour pour
antenne 2 n'est pas encore coté c'est
vallourec vallourec numéro un mondial du
tube sans soudure vallourec les exerce
son activité également dans la
métallurgie
avec ce prêt tac et les travaux publics
avec valinco pour 1986 le groupe
vallourec plonge dans le rouge
les résultats consolidés du groupe
vallourec affiche une perte de 402
millions de francs part du groupe
le marasme qui règne dans l'industrie du
pétrole a pesé sur l'activité tubes
pour 1987 les perspectives sont
également plutôt sombre sur le marché
des devises activité réduite en france
mais cela n'empêche pas le dollar de
reculer à 5 francs 96 20 la livre
sterling et ferme à 993 de deux shows
marque est en légère hausse à 3 francs
33 85 l'écu est à 6 francs 93
les cambistes plus que jamais craignent
les conséquences de la guerre
commerciale américano japonaises sur le
marché de l'or reprises à londres mais
petite baisse à paris à 86 1300 francs
le lingot d'un kilo a perdu 200 francs
et à 521 franc de napoléon a perdu 5
francs voilà williams
un coup pour rien à la bourse de paris
on se retrouve lundi en attendant vous
pouvez toujours tout savoir sur la
bourse avec votre minitel 36 15 codes
aequo à 2 merci gens suivaient pas de
bourses aux mains mais vous le saviez
sans doute nous allons maintenant
bavarder avec charlotte rampling lanoux
rage qui lui est entièrement consacrée
et pour cause ce sont des photos de vous
ça s'appelle avec les compliments de fer
l'autre en paye alors une petite
question avant que nous fêtions 7 cet
album
en général il arrive que des albums sur
les acteurs et des actrices soient
publiés sans le consentement de
l'intéressé je ferai de découper dans
les différents de l'arctique et puis là
c'est pas du tout cas non pas du tout je
les fais en collaboration avec un
éditeur allemand schirmer mosel donc
c'est lui qui est venu me demandait il
ya deux ans si on pouvait faire un livre
de ce genre uniquement sur les images
c'est ça pas de commentaire particulier
sauf une une mise en situation d'une
préface un portrait des regards depuis
un surtout petite biographie et un
épilogue de nagui saouchi m'a alors vous
les avez tout choisi où vous avez
supervisé cela prend du jambon cela leur
rigueur vous avez choisi lui par une
housse et oui c'est à dire non c'est ici
j'ai sinon on fait un travail énorme
quand je vous dire qu'on est venu dans
mon grenier ou et des photos un petit
peu n'importe où n'importe comment après
il a il a cherché à travers les films et
à travers les les photographes et les
magazines les voogd en cliquant
différentes pays a demandé aux
photographes de l'italie des photos mais
revenu dans mon grenier ce qui veut dire
que vous gardez beaucoup les photos de
travail de votre travail
oui je pense que c'est nécessaire
d'avoir
encore un souvenir un souvenir oui et
c'est plutôt ce que s est dit venir
photo nous allons fêter ensemble pendant
que nous bavardons georges beghoul à
feuilleter avant nous et nous allons
voir quelques images qui sont extraites
de cet album donc qui est publié en
france chez hatier dans la collection
aux cinq continents alors il faut dire
que c'est par ordre chronologique on
peut dire ça commence à faire vos débuts
dans les belles années soixante à
londres est-ce qu'il était facile de
devenir comédienne à l'époque il fallait
se promener avec un ça s'appelle un
press book son avis aux pouilles et
c'était moins c'était moins le cas
comme c'est maintenant de former inconnu
s'était pratiquement pas fait du tout et
j'étais une des premières inconnus à qui
on a donné une chance de tourner dans un
aqua malefoy attributs ou ça je sais pas
j'ai ils ont vu ils ont vu ma tête dans
les photos parce que je faisais un petit
peu les mannequins mais très très
brièvement il est
mais tendance et allonger les photos
vous êtes attiré par
l'apparence de mon frère test in tech
commencé ma carrière contre certaines a
créé ceux ci ont leur photographe
préféré un bien que ce soit un tel
plutôt qu'un tel qui les photographient
et elles ont probablement raison et
sinon qu'il les voit mieux quoi il les
rend plus belle ces fréquences est ce
votre cas vous avez deux trois
photographes comme j'aimais
particulièrement miaoui deux ou trois
décennies dans ce pays on sait qu israël
m le voilà il y en a plus y en a
beaucoup
voilà non ça parce que justement c'est
même pas une question de beauté c'est
une question de qui fait sortir des
choses très fortes de ces personnages
très ces photos spécialement on me
montre cette photo là que pratt rempli
mine bien qu'ils aient donc d'helmut
newton gallo qui est un très très grand
photographe ce serait très très connu et
là je ne sais pas si vous le verrez à la
caméra mais si on voit jusqu'au grain de
la peau voilà c'est ça il
on pense qu'on peut même toucher la peau
oui mais elle est très belle et très
vivant bon c'est pas une attitude
narcissique de se voir comme ça quand en
photo quand on feuillette cet album pour
le regarder volontiers housse et c'est
une chose assez difficile à faire c'est
pour ça que j'ai demandé à quand
l'éditeur demandé de le faire j'ai
préféré que c'était lui qui faisait le
sorte mise en eau du barrage et je
regarde brièvement et puis j'ai demandé
à une ou deux personnes doit être avec
moi pour le choix parce que c'est
difficile de les choisir sa semaine en
tout cas merci de venir en parler alors
c'est un album nouveau c'est pour ça
qu'on s'est permis de vous en parler
aujourd'hui parce que c'est un choix qui
a été fait en collaboration et à mon
avis c'est rarement le cas dans le dans
ce dans ce genre de publication merci de
votre visite et bonne chance à cet album
est à vos projets cinématographiques il
est maintenant 13h40 passer un oui on se
sauve
on revient demain s'est ouvert pour nous
le 1er mai à 13h en tout cas au revoir à
tous merci
e